[JINGLE]
OK, good afternoon, and welcome
to "Catching the R Wave, How
R and RStudio are
Revolutionizing Statistics
Education at Community
Colleges and Beyond."
So a little bit about me--
I've been teaching
for 25 years plus.
Various hats that I've worn
throughout those years--
I've taught K through 12.
I've taught at
four-year college,
and I've taught at
two-year college.
I've taught computer science.
I've taught mathematics
at all of the introductory
undergraduate levels.
So it's a lot of teaching.
I spent five years at
Great Bay Community College
in Portsmouth, New Hampshire.
And while there, I was the
chair of the Math Department
and in charge of the
Engineering Program.
And I also created one of the
nation's first certificates
in practical data science
at a community college.
Also, I'm married
to Harbormaster,
if you know him, on Twitter.
So I have created a
GitHub that contains
all of the materials that
are relevant to this talk.
It's also a work in progress.
I'm actually trying
to put together
some materials that can turn
into one, cohesive thing
that a teacher can then
just use as a handbook
for any stats class
and any textbook
that they might choose to use.
So just a quick survey--
raise your hand if you've either
attended a community college
or have taught at a
community college.
Wow, it's more than
I was expecting.
That's really cool.
It was about half the room.
So let's do just a real,
quick overview of just
of a history of why I became
passionate about community
college education.
Why is this such a big deal?
There are over 1,000 community
colleges in the United States.
That's a map of them made
in R. Only 20 of them--
maybe a few more.
We keep adding a
couple every year,
but it's under 20 that actually
have a program right now,
whether it's or certificate,
or an associate's
degree, or something, that's
either called data science
or data analytics.
Compared to the over 1,000,
we have a little bit of a ways
to go.
As a comparison, we did
not make this graph in R.
This was copied off
of a report that
was put out by the government.
But compared two-year
to four-year colleges,
we have about 36%
of all students
who were undergraduates
in the year 2016.
36% were in two-year colleges--
which is more than 1/3.
And it's kind of surprising
to hear that number.
Most people think that
it's not quite that much,
because we think about all
the undergraduate colleges
out there.
And you're like,
well, it can't be.
But it is.
And as far as the
numbers of students
who receive bachelor's degrees--
I think this was 2015/16.
Of all the bachelor's
degrees awarded in that year,
49% of those students
had started out
at a community college--
49%, almost 1/2.
State by state, it does differ.
The highest percentage is Texas,
where we are right now, at 75%.
So they're really pushing
community college education.
The lowest is
Rhode Island at 24.
You can barely see it there.
But it's there.
So why did I become
passionate about this?
Because what
happens is a student
comes out of high school--
and even adults who might want
to go back for a credential--
but especially high
school students.
Let's focus on
them for a second.
They start out at a
community college.
And they get a list of programs
that they could sign up for.
And very few of them--
or not many of them--
are really comfortable
with math or science.
You have few engineering
people who just are
determined to do engineering.
That's kind of a unique crowd.
But most students
pick a program,
and then they stick with that.
They're not going to
diverge from that--
hence, the road.
And what I would
like to see is I
would like to see
more students exposed
to data science in
the community college
setting so that then,
when they transfer
to a four-year college,
they're sort of on a track
to continue that kind
of work, and maybe
do research-driven work, and
maybe choose a STEM major.
So I just wanted to show you the
program sheet for the Practical
Data Science as it exists
right now at Great Bay.
Great Bay Community
College is located
in Portsmouth, New Hampshire.
It's about an hour
north of Boston.
So I was able to use the
fact that it's close enough
to Boston as a sort
of justification
for creating the program.
All of those courses are
liberal arts courses.
They can transfer to
any four-year college
as a liberal arts course.
I deliberately got them
categorized as that.
So along with this
work that I was
doing to create the certificate,
I was also thinking,
how can we make it
easier for students
to make the transition from
Excel, or from their Texas
Instruments--
whatever technology
they're used to--
how do we get them comfortable
with R, especially in that--
the first course that I teach
in the data science curriculum
is called Elements
of Data Science.
And typically, it takes three
weeks out of a 15-week semester
just to get students
up and running in R,
believe it or not.
So I'm seeing a lot of nods.
Well, so what if we
started introducing R
in some of our other
coursework, like even
in a biology class, or
in a chemistry class,
or a physics class?
And then, in my case, since
I was in charge of the Math
Department, I could point
to the statistics class
and tell all my
statistics instructors,
this is what we're
going to do, and this
is how we're going to do it.
And I'm with you.
I'm supporting you.
I'm going to teach you.
We're going to work
on this together.
We're going to
stumble a little bit.
The first couple of
times we tried it,
it was terrible--
and especially here.
Because in 2014, that's
when we started doing it.
And the feedback we were
getting from students
was, oh, man, you're
asking me to learn
programming and statistics
at the same time,
and I can't do it.
It's too hard.
But fast forward to 2018,
2019 and now I'm like,
wow, how can we get
R into the classroom?
How can we get it
into more classrooms?
It's really cool.
It's really working--
so, very enthusiastic.
And just a shout out
for RStudio Cloud here--
RStudio Cloud has
been invaluable
for the Elements of
Data Science class.
I don't use it in
the Statistics class.
And after the talk, if you
would like to know why,
I can explain.
But RStudio Cloud is used in
our Elements of Data Science.
And most of the course
outcomes involve
wrangling data, finding
the data sets that
will answer a question
that you want to answer,
and then coming up with that
tidy data set at the end.
And it takes a whole
semester to do that.
We'll just be honest.
But before we talk about
how to incorporate R
into the statistics
classroom, let's
talk a little bit about why.
So here's an example.
Actually, this was a
slide from a lecture
that Pearson Publishing
produces for instructors
of just intro stats.
So this is just a page out
of a lecture for intro stats.
And yes, you're going
to learn something.
If you answer this
question correctly,
you've learned something.
But have you learned what
we want you to learn?
What have you learned?
You've learned how
to use a formula,
how to convert from
an x to a z value.
So I know how to use a formula.
And you've learned how
to use the z-table.
That's it.
There's no kinds
of questioning here
that involves any
kind of deep learning
or any kind of analysis.
Why are we getting
what we're getting--
just nothing like that.
So the Math Department at
Great Bay Community College--
namely, myself.
And just so you know, I'm
a collaborative leader.
I was not just somebody who
said, we're going to do this.
We all met together.
I met with all of my adjuncts.
And I said, OK, here's
what we're faced with.
This is this is what
I'm thinking about.
What do you think?
And just getting
everybody on board with it
is a big, big, big deal.
Getting your stakeholders
and the people
that you're going to be
asking to do all of the work--
it's important to
get them on board
and to get them
enthusiastic about it,
or you're not going
to go very far.
But anyway, we decided
to make technology period
a big part of the curriculum
throughout the Math Department.
So one of the one of my
favorite courses to teach
is Finite Math.
You do input/output analysis.
There's these things
that you can actually
do in R in a finite math class.
It doesn't even have
to be statistics.
And we were doing matrices
in R. It makes sense.
Whenever a student
comes up to me and says,
ugh, it's too hard,
I just point to this.
I'm like, and that's easy?
Tell me what about this is easy.
And what about it is--
OK, I've got this
tiny little thing.
If I happened to
be sight impaired,
there's no way that
I'm going to be
able to get to read anything
off of that tiny little screen
on that Casio.
If you've never seen one of
those Casio calculators--
I should have put a
picture up for you.
Whenever I show instructors--
when I am in a room with a
bunch of community college
instructors and I
show them this--
and I'm going to
be honest with you.
I usually go to
that R-D-I-O dot--
I don't know.
It's a snippets thing.
So I usually just go there.
And I Copy and Paste this in.
Boom, here comes the output.
And I'm like, you can do this.
You can do this.
And usually, the
instructors are--
wow, can I do that on my phone?
And I say, well,
yeah, because you
have a browser on your phone.
If it's a smartphone,
you have a browser.
So you bring up the
window that actually has
that executable window in it.
Just Copy and Paste--
and yeah, of course.
So, they're amazed.
And they begin to
buy into this idea.
And I'm also going
to admit, this
is an actual image of
a spreadsheet template
that I used in my
Intro Stats class.
Apologies to anybody
who had me at that time.
It was designed so that you
could just put in the values
that you needed to, and out
would come all of the value.
So you didn't have
to use a table.
And I'm sorry, but after
that talk this morning--
you heard the keynote, right?
This is programming.
I just want to put
that out there.
This is programming.
The same output in R with
only a few lines of code
basically is just-- and
you'll see this in my GitHub.
The code for this
is in the GitHub.
It's just amazing when
I show the contrast
with educators about how
much more use you can
get with this kind of output.
So here I was--
at that point, when
we had the cloud
and I was using just these
little snippets of code,
I was all excited.
And now all of the
sudden, Shiny is here.
And now I have to admit, I
haven't played with Shiny yet.
But I'm getting the point
across from many people
that I need to.
So everyone's telling me
yeah, you really need to.
But it's actually going to be
helping in this whole effort
to try to get community
college instructors
on the board with us.
Because Cal Poly, Penn State--
and I'm sure there's more--
they have published Shiny
apps that are specifically
for the intro stats class.
And hey, I'm going
to check them out.
And then, in addition to that,
StatPREP is an effort that
began as a collaboration between
the Mathematical Association
of America and then this
organization called AMATYC,
which is American Mathematical
Association of Two-Year
Colleges--
AMATYC.
And then also NSF is supporting
the funding for this.
And ASA, as well, is involved.
And what are they doing?
They have these
traveling workshops
that are at various
locations around the country.
Anybody can apply if you are
an undergraduate educator.
You don't have to be full time.
You can be part time.
You can just apply.
And look to see if
there's a workshop that's
somewhat close to you.
But you can actually get a
whole group of people to go.
That's what they want.
They want colleges to send
a whole team of educators.
And I put my own text over
there, so you could read it.
The next webinar is coming up.
It's this Friday, January 25.
And it's about
introducing students
to multi-variable
data-- students who've
never seen it before.
So it's a really good
effort that Katie is doing.
And if you go under the
About and the People--
it's all on my GitHub,
as far as who's involved
and how you can get
involved to help, as well.
One of the Shiny apps that
the StatPREP team uses is--
this is just an example for you
where they use these Shiny apps
for their training.
So they're actually showing
instructors what a function is,
what parameters are.
What are these things
inside of the parentheses?
And seriously, if
you've ever used Excel,
there's a natural connection
between what goes on
with functions in Excel and what
goes on with functions in R.
It's not that difficult
to make that transition.
Also, the American
Statistical Association
has provided materials, as well.
There's data.
If you're looking
for data, go there.
Here's what we need.
We need your help.
Community colleges
need your help.
If you've ever been in a
community college, you know.
We can make a difference.
And we can make data literacy
a reality in our culture.
We want to make smarter,
better educators.
Go out there to your
local community college.
Make a relationship with
the instructors there.
Just start a relationship.
Start a conversation.
Find out what their needs are--
a whole lot of
educating going on.
We want to make all
these dots programs
with something relating to data
science or some kind of intro.
And if you're a
developer, make apps that
are available for any device--
any device.
Bottom line-- is this the R
experience we want or this?
Thank you for having me.
I want to thank all of these
people that reached out to me.
And special thanks to my
husband, who seriously really
helped me prepare this talk.
There's my get hub
link again if you
want to take a picture of it.
And here's where
you can find me--
so, thank you.